[Music]
let's go to john in new orleans what's
up brother john
hey dr john how you doing today i'm all
right my brother how are you
i'm redefining the word good or not
equity uh i can already tell i'm sorry
man tell me about it what's going on
um
38 days ago my daughter
had some blood in her stool
and next thing we knew it was sugar
toxin e coli
which produced into hus causing her
kidneys to fail they had to um
life flighter from the hospital we were
at to a much bigger hospital here in new
orleans and then
uh the next morning she coded for two
and a half hours um
he's probably the most terrifying and
amazing thing i've ever seen yeah um
for two and a half hours as they did
chest compressions and then they put her
on ecmo
and uh she was on ecmo for eight days
on event for another
um 15 or well she was on event for a
total of 15 days
and
we were told that
there was a two percent chance of her
kidneys redundant function and
we had some pretty horrible
conversations with some doctors and
we've had some uh
we made some pretty horrible decisions
that parents should never have to make
and before we made probably the worst
decision a parent could make we asked
about transferring to another hospital
and we did that and everything changed
i mean
everything
the next morning they were going to
start the dialysis again and
we saw a blue line on her diaper and
she's
she's her kidneys the kidney doctor told
us uh two days ago that it's a 90
recovery of her kidneys
but the bigger thing is is that during
that two and a half hours of cpr
she suffered global
brain damage to the deep brain tissue
yep
and
her left side has been mostly paralyzed
but
doctors told us that she would
probably never be able to do much of
anything and
i'm telling you when i originally
emailed the show to it today it's so
different but
she's she's smiling she's she's laughing
she's she's
trying to clap her hands it's it's so
amazing to see how resilient this little
baby is
um but
i mean we're
living a parent with nightmare and we've
got a long way to go and we don't know
we don't know what the end is gonna look
like
so first and foremost dude
like fast if we were just hanging out
i'll give you a hug
and i'd probably hold it a little too
long
okay
i'm sorry man
me too
um
gosh there's so much here
i guess the the first thing is y'all
y'all got a rare opportunity
to rappel down into the bowels of hell
and
have to ask questions and have
conversations that no parent ever ever
ever should have to have
and
to resolve to make decisions that no
parent should have to have and then find
out that had you made that decision it
might not have been the right or you
don't mean yet you've been
in heavy trauma
right
absolutely yes
um hey uh do me a favor talk directly
into the phone for me
oh there we go um
and then you've got the illness does
everybody blaming everybody for this
parents beat themselves up horrifically
over things like this
yeah that was um
yeah it's
how how can we cope with the guilt of
not
not protecting her better like you know
like that's our job
um so yeah dealing with that has been
been rough yeah
i think the
protection is something we strive for
but in many ways it's an illusion
true and you got to see
i mean you just got your bubble burst on
that illusion
sooner than most right
um in a much more horrific way than most
right usually people find that out when
their kids are in a car wreck or they
break an arm or they you know get
covered or something and here's
end up with
jeez
hut i mean she's louise man what a mess
kidney failure
um
i think that ultimately you got to sit
down and grieve this whole thing start
to finish and y'all aren't there yet
and so the pressure you putting on
yourself right now to
solve this what do we do now i'm gonna
tell you what you do right now as you
get to tomorrow
and then you get to the next day then
you get to the next day you're in mile
14 of a marathon
and you're trying to figure out how you
can best massage your calves
and best fix your hurting hip you got to
finish the race and y'all still got a
ways to go does that make sense
yes
i would love to see
y'all take care of your basic needs
eating
and sleeping
and being with other people do you have
other kids
yeah we've got a we've got a
five-year-old daughter geez louise
um
so those conversations are tough too
right
correct yeah that was um you know we
were i originally it was like how do i
explain to my five-year-old that her
sister isn't coming home but now it's
how do i explain to my five-year-old
that when her sister does come home that
she's not going to be the same
in very clear simple terms
kids won't have the same baggage that
you and i will have
and they will be very more
very much more understanding
so it's as simple as
little sis got very very sick and so
she's not going to be able to move her
left leg and her left foot very well
and then a natural question for a
six-year-old or a five-year-old is well
am i going to get that sick
and you say no probably not it's very
very very rare it almost never happens
but little sis got it
and so we're gonna have to help out and
you are gonna get to really help your
baby sister
and
using words like her baby and her baby
sister will give her some autonomy and
some ownership
and that helps quell that in that
anxiety
and that little girl is going to absorb
mom and dad's grief and sadness and
that's okay
what's
really important though is that y'all
communicate with her we're very sad
about little sister
not like no it's all good we're just
plugging along and we're in fake smiling
in front of your six-year-old or
five-year-old because she's gonna absorb
the tension and she's gonna think it's
her fault
and she's gonna absorb the gap between
what she feels and what y'all are saying
and what she's seeing with her sister
and so it's just being really honest and
saying words like i'm really sad
i'm really sad that baby got really sick
daddy's really sad that um he wanted to
protect his little girl and she got sick
from a little tiny old bug that i
couldn't protect him from
and um
i'm very very sad that she got so sick
it's being that kind of honest and that
that language that she can understand
not overthinking it
and also not belaboring it all the time
too does that make sense
yes
yes um
what i'd really love y'all to see is
y'all get home
and get settled at home and sleep in
your own bed together as as all four of
you
and then as the reality of this begins
to set in because right now you're still
running on fumes and you're still
running on adrenaline and cortisol and
you get home and are able to exhale
that's when the deep grief of this thing
will go
okay
number two we haven't been home and
since this whole thing started that's
right and so you haven't slept your
mind's not clear you're probably not
eating
very well
um do you have people coming to the
hospital to be with you guys
yeah we've got a very good support
system okay it would be a gift to you
and to them to give them some very
detailed jobs
i need someone to go mow my yard i need
someone to go vacuum my house and wipe
down the kitchen cabinets
i need someone to bring us food and
vegetables and fruits we don't do
mcdonald's again right so very specific
jobs and you've got a team of people
around you who are dying for something
to do to be a part of this and help
and you're gonna have to say here's what
i need and let them go chase that down
is that cool yeah we've
we've been doing that we've got a really
good like i said really good support
system great and yeah we're eating too
much i'm eating too much
probably not eating enough dude i would
be
yeah i don't even want it yeah i would
not be taking care of myself very well
um but there's it comes a moment when
taking care of yourself well um i'm
gonna ask you a really hard question
okay
okay um
and so no i'm going to ask you a hard
question and no it's not a kind question
but i want to be real direct with you
okay
did you intentionally feed your little
girl something infected with e coli with
the intention of making her sick
absolutely not then this is not your
fault
okay
you hear me
yeah it's not your fault
and i'll go further to say
any meditation on this is our fault this
is us we should have we we should have
is a choice to take
it's a it's a false control over
something that's already happened with a
period at the end
okay
so the greatest gift you can give
yourself your wife your marriage your
kid and say the same goes for your your
wife too
is to live as much as possible in the
right now
and one thing that the doctors seem to
have proven to you over and over again
is their predictions are terrible
all right
yeah and she's defined the odds both for
the good and the bad there you go
and my gut tells me is she'll continue
to
that's that's what we're hoping for the
therapies that are available to young
children again i'm not in the business
of false hope the number of parents i've
had to tell them that i've i've been the
guy that comes and sits in that little
square room with you and your wife and
says your baby's not gonna make it okay
so i'm not in the business of giving
false hope
um my oldest best friend on the planet
is a traumatic brain survivor and the
change in technology and therapies that
they have been able to come up with over
the last 20 years is astounding
and i tell you that to tell you i think
you've got every reason to walk out of
that hospital with your head held high
okay
and quite frankly the other alternative
is to walk out with your head held low
and that's not going to get anybody
anything
do be heartbroken and it'd be really sad
right
yeah and dude you're gonna keep doing it
for a while and there's gonna come a
moment when she's four
and she's either running around the
neighborhood and you're gonna be
grieving over what almost was or you'll
be pushing her and
some futuristic looking wheelchair while
out at the zoo and it will just overcome
you with like a wave
that how unfair it is that she's not
running around the other kids and it
will be what it is and let that thing
come and feel it and own it
and then bend down and give that girl a
kiss right on her big sweaty forehead
and say let's go see the lions
right
yes
but you are in the middle of this and
this is not that moment
this is the moment to be with your wife
to be with your baby little girl to be
with your five-year-old
and i keep telling the doctors not in
this house
right
yeah i'm
i'm glad we
didn't make
make the decision that everyone was
telling us we needed to make yes be at
peace with that
yeah
and
and
forgive yourself for even contemplating
it
okay okay
you got to stop hanging on to it man
yeah
yeah
you had to dance with the devil and then
you backed out it's good
good for you what made y'all change
hospitals
um
honestly it was the dialysis um she was
going from acute to chronic
and the hospital we were at did not do
chronic dialysis
so we had to go to the children's
hospital that that does the chronic
dialysis
so that that was the driving force of
the move
wow that's fantastic man and then just
so when she your child moved over they
just their care was just different and
better and she got
she perked up
um
something happened in the ambulance on
the way between the two hospitals
she she fell asleep for the first time
in
days she didn't she pretty much didn't
wake up for about 36 hours
and
that was you know
that was when everything started to
change wow i mean everything it was
they were legitimately there to hook the
dialysis machine up
and we were repositioning her when we
noticed the blue line on our diapers so
that they could get access to the
catheter ports yeah
dude that's amazing
and each day has gotten better each day
we're getting a little bit more of her
back
but there's still a lot of
a lot of remission of course and there
and honestly there might be
there might be
um
and that's not for today
is that fair
yes
um do keep this uh i want you to get
away from the hospital if you can in the
next day or two
get out to some sunshine and i want you
to go pick up a journal
at a barnes noble or someplace
and i want you to begin writing it down
all of it
what you feel what you think what you're
upset about what you're mad about what
you're scared about
and the goal is when she turns 18 you're
gonna hand this over to her
and you're gonna say this is the journey
we took with you
this is how much we loved you this is
how long we've loved you
this is a shadow of how much we're gonna
continue to love you moving forward
but write all that stuff down
for you for your wife for your little
one your five-year-old for everybody
i'm grateful for you man and my heart is
broken for you
i wish i had something that i could stop
my fingers i can't um i can just tell
you as it does another dad i love you
and i'm so sorry
so so sorry man